you know luca you look at the west
and you see a uh a plethora of
injuries around you know the lakers on
full strength
your team your team is in full strength
you know portland cj mccollum's coming
back
you know i could go down the line you
know everyone healthy
on your team what would what would
propel you to be
that team that says we are now
contenders and not just play off a
playoff team
i mean i think obviously this is an
injury because you know we
it's a crazy rhythm we play almost every
other game a lot of back-to-backs
but you know we when we fool you know
we're just trying to go game by game
first
uh escape the play-in tournament so we
can be straight in the playoffs
and then going from there game by game
last thing from me luca is this
uh you and dwight howard tied with the
most technical fouls
with 15 and if you get one more you get
suspended a game
over your last six are you going to
remain
luca and play to high level but also not
let your emotions get out of control
yeah for sure you know this season has
been long you know i
with the fish i wasn't myself this
season you know i've
complaining way too much and i gotta
work on that you know and now
i just gotta stay calm and just not talk
to them i gotta learn from that
nothing to complain about tonight 113
109 the final score as
luca doncic goes for 24-10 and no one
likes referees
thanks a lot for hanging out with us we
appreciate you